it's really frustrating to care about the conversation of sustainability
when existing in inherently capitalist society
that does not care about the environment
constantly like at odds at my
you know desire to support the earth and you know
understanding of
you know climate changing global warming and all that
and also fatigue from existing in society
knowing that none of the actions that I take will actually matter because of
not joking maybe like 100 people
like for the rest of my life
I will be subjected to straws that disintegrate in my mouth
and that will still not outweigh the negative impact of a 30 minute flight
that Taylor Swift takes
from one end of a state to another
and so it just
it's it’s it’s frustrating and I'm like
why does it matter
I can do all the things
I can do all the things that
you know help the environment and I'm not gonna not do
but it just feels so
and it just makes it hard for me to
care about conversations about sustainability
because we're just
we're we're doing
minute change when we need to get to the root of the issue and I just
I just I just feel this doomerism when it comes to sustainability
and the conversation about that like literally makes me feel like a boomer
but I honestly don't know how to reckon with that either
I don't know anyways